>>> MORE BREAKING NEWSRNSTIE LA
NEW ED IT N ,
FO
VI, MILAUGHT
IS NOT LEADER.
LLMEY.
[ LA ]RSON IM TALKINT  OSE MIRRI
DONALDNG THA
ANT
CONVERSATIONH YOU, W
DESERVE TO ASK FVEERSHIP.
WE D'T TO HAVE Y
TH UWORTHY OF
LESHIP.RMER GOVERNOR
CHRISTIE TONIGHT.
HE HAS FOUD A BUMP
HIORMER
PRESIDENT AND DRPE HE FOLD AS BR
AGAIN TRUMP SUPPORTER THEN BROK
6th.
HERE'S A SAMPLING OF SOME OF TH6
RACE AND RUN-UP TO TONIGHT.GE C
IT.
>>N HI T
TOWER AND PHON I I'M ANY
RV HE HAS EVEN IF HE
CAN 140
OLEN FM ATRIOTIC  CONST EVE THEI
SQUALIFIED
BEING ID THE UNITED
STATES AKEEP LOSINANNG.
AND THMA
W LOSING
BECAUSE ELF BEFORE EVERYBODY EL
CADEMIC  CRITIQUVOTES.
JOINR OBL
ADVISER VAJOAN
AN, ALSOHI
ORGER.
WHATISE HIS LANE IS.
>>T ANI ASKED HIS SENIOR
ADVISER AND  SAID, CHRIS' LANE
ISS THE ONLY WAY C
CHAKE HIM ON
FWHICH QUITE THE OTHER CANDIDAT
CHRISTIE AND
REMB ON MARC
DESTROYED S
HIM.
D MARCO
BUT HE PROCESS AND ITHIN A LITTE
BECAUSE HE'S N REALLEPUBLICAELAL
>>ENANT GOVERNORDO YOU TE HAS A
RAID TO LOSE DANGEROUS
COMBINATION FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
MUSIC NEEDSO O HAVE T
STIC THEATS  GOVERNOR IN A BLU
LO THAVE
HAS.
THK TO
THAT SCO
HAMMER.
>> CHRIS CHRSHEDOTION HES MPGOGP
ARY.
WIN THIS THING>> HE HAE SAME CH
NOMINATIONHEORT INY
THATIVE PEOPLE  THE SINGLE GIUTI
THINK
IT'S IMPNTNTRY
BODY
WITH HISD COE  CHALL A.N REMARK
E LIKEP
ABOUT HIM.CO WHITE HOUSE, LOSTT
HIS CHANCE OF
SAME C GETTINGHI
S THE GREERT
ZERO. E'S
Y A
ROLLER COAST
DOHAIMBILITY
OBER>> YEAH, I IY
I MEAN, WE AR
WAS PREPNGTRUMP FOR TE WHEN OU
CAUGHT COVID.
AFTER THAT DPPORTING DONALD UMTD
TO ME, LOOK,
THAT DISTINCTION THAT AFTEARY 6
COULR SUPPORT DOUMIS A FLIP SID'
OUERY YING, RUMP BR OFCAY D T WF
W HE'D THIS
IF WORK
S HAVET OV
THAT HUMP OFU SO  HIM AND N HAT
>> DYOTHINK THE RACE CANDIDATES
TODAY, I'MITED TO SEALIFIED CANS
I THINK WE HAVE TO OUREST WARD.
ALSO ONE OF THOSE REPUBLICAN
THAT IS TH
GRAVITY WILL CATCH UP TO
TRUMP.
HE WIL THREE O
INDICTMENTS AT WRAPPEDAROUND HI
DIVIDEP VOTE, YOU KNOW, THOSE
WHO DON'T WANT TMPE HAS
A BASE OF 30%, 35%, ISN'T THAT
>> IT'S A MATH PRO EVERIELD OUT
HAVE A WHOLE SW OF TM AND
CHRIS CHRISTIE, TIM SCOT NKILEY
IDATES THAT COULD
LEGITIMATELY WIN A NOMINATION.
BUT GOTO HAVE DONALD TRUMP APAR
POSSIBLE.
THE PROBLEISAM  THE NDG MEN WI
WHAT HAPPENED  DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, BERNIE SANDWA.
SCARED THEEE OF
EVERY.NE PERSOGO
BIDEVERYONEDOCTTHERE AN
A S SENSES,
ERODLIKED-AR.DE COROKER
OF YOU GET OUT OF MY WAY, LET ME
GONEE BUT  WILDROP OUT BEFORE S
WIN ON THE SCOREBOARD.
>> GLORIA,IRSTEPUBLICAN IMARY DA
RULE OF SUPPORTIHEIN
ANSWERED RIGHT NOW.
TO ANSWER THAT
K CHRIS CHRISTIE
HOP NOW I
, BUT
TO GET ON THAT DEBATE STAGE.
HO BE ABLE  TAKE ON
DO TRUMP IF DONALD TRUMP
IPATES, REMEMBER, DONALD  SAYIN
WOD  I'VCH
LAE PERJURY OFHCENTAGE OF T V